uh Benjamin Netanyahu is now set for the
third time to become Israel's next prime
minister right now he's currently in
talks to build his governing Coalition
he's pledging to govern in the interests
of all Israelis and meanwhile Netanyahu
is also calling on the Biden
Administration to reaffirm their
relationship with the Saudis warning of
the dangers to the wild swings in that
relationship anyway here to explain so
much more the author of Bibi my story
incoming Israeli Prime Minister the
longest serving prime minister in his
real history Israeli history uh Benjamin
Netanyahu Mr Prime Minister it's great
to be able to call you that once again I
thought we had wild elections here in
the States but I think Israel tops all
you have what five elections in three
years
well we've become a juggernaut of
innovation on a global scale as you know
in technology but it seems to me that we
were doing this also in the instability
of politics but uh I'm very glad to say
that the people of Israel gave me a very
strong vote of confidence we uh have a
an election that finally decided the
impasse that we had in the Israeli
political system and we're moving ahead
for the benefit as you uh rightly quoted
all Israelis and for peace and Security
in our region and for the alliance
between Israel and America I I don't
think the relationship between Israel
and the US was stronger than when you
were prime minister and Donald Trump was
President that's when uh of course the
embassy got moved to Jerusalem from Tel
Aviv that's when President Trump
recognized uh Israel's right to Golan
Heights uh and you had a great
partnership but something else happened
the the United States the Israelis the
jordanians the Saudis the Emirates all
United against Iranian hegemony I've
said many times that you have always
been the voice of moral Clarity against
radicalism in the Mideast uh you remain
that that Soul voice yet again today
however there are more people jumping on
board fearful of an Iran with nuclear
weapons
this is precisely true I think the rise
of uh Iranian aggression and Iranian
power its quest for nuclear weapons
threatens the entire world they they
chant death to Israel death to America
uh and all the infidels in in between uh
in their view so blocking them was
important a to uh is continually
important in order to assure the Peace
of our region the Peace of the world but
alongside the rise of Iranian power came
the rise of Israeli power I talk in my
book how we transformed Israel uh from a
socialist economy to one of the most
robust free market economies uh in the
world we expanded our intelligence
capabilities our cyber capabilities and
as a result another thing happened
alongside with the threat of Iran and
that is the the the the change in the
way that Arab leaders began to look at
Israel not as their enemy but is their
indispensable Ally to probably raining
in aggression and also to benefit their
people from our incredible technology
that created the background for the
Abraham Accords which was achieved with
the help of President Trump and his team
and so we made four historic Peace
Accords and I believe more are in the
office so we have in our area two things
that are happening one the rise of a
rogue regime that could threaten the
Peace of the entire planet and the
second the rise of uh of Peace treaties
that could uh serve both to Stave off
aggression but also to offer a better
future for all and basically I'm coming
back to office to advance both goals
block Iran expand the piece uh Mr Prime
Minister I hope people do have a chance
to pick up your book about your life
what an incredible life you've LED uh
part of an elite military force along
with your brother your brother was
killed at the rate at antebe your life
story is phenomenal the longest serving
prime minister in Israeli history and
now back for a third time uh we uh we
really appreciate you being out on the
world stage and steadfastly sticking up
with that moral Clarity that I think the
world needs to adhere to Mr Prime
Minister thank you for being with us
thank you Sean I like your time good
luck to you God bless America I'll send
you a new one and all although it might
get you in trouble in Israel I don't
know uh but absolutely it would
can't have a second thank you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else